je lui julie oui parce qu'est ce qu'un
casimir tu m'as l'air bien énervé est-ce
que tu as une glace oui à quel parfum
nous en choix sans doute mais non je ne
veux pas une glace pour manger je veux
glace dans laquelle on se regarde un
miroir explique toi mieux étant donné à
mon avis oui minute papillon
merci ça paris ce que signifie cette
comédie saba je suis beau hein je suis
vraiment beau qu'une pompe en bas
casimir tuer un monstre sympathique
est ce que tu crois que me suis dit si
noble et jaloux de ma beauté
ben franchement kazimierz ça
m'étonnerait alors il est devenu fou
complètement fou et qu'il était quasi
france mais il faut faire quelque chose
c'est terrible monsieur du snob est
devenu fou il ne sait plus ce qu'il dit
c'est terrible ça qu'ils ignoraient que
là tu entendu dire il a dit que j'étais
les avants ce n'est que ça moi mais mes
françois c'est très grave
tu sais bien que je suis bout comme tous
les 15 me ruphin il n'a jamais existé un
casimir us et les erreurs casimir tu as
oublié l'histoire de nos ancêtres
casimir et annonce je m'en souviens très
bien ma grand mère me l'a raconté quand
j'étais tout petit comme ça à vrai dire
françois c'est plutôt une légende on ne
suit pas vraiment si casimir est
exister c'est aussi ce que ma grand-mère
me disait mais c'est une histoire que
j'aimais beaucoup
ouais c'est une très belle les cheveux
mais françois tu pourrais il a raconté
aux enfants à jour c'est une bonne idée
ça et pourquoi pas aujourd'hui
oui mais oui pour l'heure c'est une très
bonne idée
j'appelle les enfants nés hors liens
avec moi a raconté une histoire dont
celui de raconter une histoire
formidable
vous allez voir c'est une histoire que
je connaissais déjà mélangé katie et
c'est vraiment une casimir tu es pressé
de d'écouter l'histoire
et alors eh bien je n'attends plus que
toi pour commencer l'histoire de casimir
est mais j'étais content pour bien jouer
le rôle de casimir est bon ce ne sera
pas facile parce qu'il était très laid
andy comme moi je suis beau mais je veux
bien essayer pour l'heure givet qui
saigne et bien ça se passait il y
environ 2 millions 300 mille quatre cent
treize ans non 414 casimir j'aimerais ne
pas interrompu pour un détail sans
importance
alors donc quoi l'un de nous qu coûte
que j'ai mise puisque c'est comme ça moi
je me rends au nom non vas-y tu t'en vas
pas bon la faute à son chat noir dont
les 400 crise puisque c'est 414 son sens
puisqu'il casimir c'est fini lui
oui oui j'écoute car je peux commencer
d'accord non alors cette année là
casimir et arrive à un âge où les
cuisiniers russes l'arrière mais fait
exceptionnel dans l'histoire des casiers
russe kazimir ai été très long il devait
rassembler à monsieur du snob le casimir
sépare très très gentil ce que tu dirais
l'écoutent casimir tu as promis de jouer
le rôle de casimir est alors
concentre-toi ah bon d'accord bon donc
casimir est était très laid et aucune
des demoiselles casimir us ne voulait de
lui un jour casimir est parti dans la
montagne à la recherche d'un très gros
baobab lorsqu'il lui trouver il a bâti
avec sa hache est rien puis sur le tronc
de l'arbre
il sculpte à une magnifique jeune fille
il revêtit de son sous vêtement de
couleur vive à son cou il mit un collier
d'or à ses poignets des bracelets de
cuir puis sur sa tête
il posa un coquillage magique plat des
plots qui avait le pouvoir de donner la
vie alors la jeune fille sculptées dans
le bois de baobab se mit à vivre et
casimir et lui dit tu seras ma belle
épouse tu t'appelles à 15 émirats et
nous irons vivre ensemble de l'autre
côté de l'île là où le soleil se lève à
puis casimir est emmené à sa jeune
épouse à travers la forêt à cette
époque-là n'irai pas encore d'enfant
dans notre île mais beaucoup d'espèces
animales l'habitait soudain ils
rencontrèrent un animal très gros très
grand et très fort quel animal était ce
un dragon c'était un dragon le dragon
s'adressa casimir est lui dix 10 mois
casimir est que là une fort belle épouse
battons-nous pour elle et le vainqueur
l'emportera avec casimir elle ne pouvait
pas refuser
il était beaucoup plus petit beaucoup
moins fort que le dragon et surtout il
voulait pas passer pour un lâche
au moment où le combat allait s'engager
on entendit la voix de kazimira qui
disait ne tombe pas casimir est je suis
un arbre sauvage et puissants ne tombe
pas mon casimir est à l'instant même le
dragon s'écroula par terre en dix ans ou
bien ça alors casimir et jamais je ne
l'aurais cru aussi fort puis casimir et
et casimir a poursuivi leur chemin
et bientôt ils rencontrèrent en outre à
lui
un animal très puissant et très fier à
votre avis quel était cet animal un
rhinocéros au rhinocéros s'adressa à
casimir et lui dit dis-moi casimir et
que là une très très belle épouse
battons-nous pour elle de nouveau le
combat allait s'engager
lorsqu on entendit la voix de kazimira
il disait frappe de toute ta force
casimir est je suis un arbre sauvage et
puissants ne tombe pas mon casimir et
aussitôt le rhinocéros tomba par terre
en disant ah bah ça alors j'en reviens
pas casimir est vraiment que le plus
puissant casimir est et casimir à
reprirent leur chemin et bientôt arriver
revue village des tyrannosaures qui
était vous le savez les plus féroces de
tous les animaux de l'île
casimir est dit à casimir à attends-moi
casimir
je vais explorer les environs mais
surtout cache toi si tu vois un féroce
tyrannosaure puis il partit à ce moment
là casimir a vite arrivé le chef des
tyrannosaures entouré de tous ses
serviteurs elle fut tellement ébloui
qu'elle nous a pas bougé et resta là
pétrifie le chef philosophe lui dit
alors qui es-tu je suis les pousses de
casimir est bien avec moi il le chef
tyrannosaure casimir oeufs et lait très
pauvres tandis que moir moi je suis très
riche et casimir a suivi le chef
tyrannosaures et quand casimir et revin
il l'a cherché partout partout jusque
dans le village des crânes aux ailes
comme il passait près de la maison du
chef du ran azor celui-ci l'interpella
et lui dit va-t-en casimir est battante
puis tu râlais très pauvre ton épouse
préfère rester avec moi alors
casimir et lui dit donnant lui seulement
de me rendre mon coquillages des émirats
jeter par la fenêtre le coquillage
à l'instant même elle se transforma en
animant ce baobab qui en poussant
défonça le toit de la maison du chef
tyrannosaure casimir est on track triste
non chez lui mais le récit de ses
exploits étaient déjà connues de tous et
une grande fête fête organisée en son
honneur
[Musique]